what's going on guys I am super excited
about today's episode we are going on
our first ever official movie set visit
on screen junkies and the movie is Keanu
starring keegan-michael key and Jordan
Peele of comedy central's key and Peele
it opens April 29th but we got a sneak
peek behind the scenes and I'm gonna eat
craft service see how a movies made and
talk to the stars let's check it out
so I had made the perilous journey from
Los Angeles to New Orleans
to visit my first-ever movie set for
screen junkies and when I got to set I
quickly noticed one thing here's
something I learned on set if you are
doing a set visit from screen junkies
you will die of heat exhaustion but if
you're one of the you're one of the main
actors they will fan you the royal
treatment that to fan the double fan I
am sweating like a stuck pig well I may
have been drenched with sweat but I
still had a job to do it was time to
talk to the cast of Keanu it is so hot
and it begs the question why are you
shooting here we really felt that you
know the the great benefit of New
Orleans as a destination is that it's
cheaper Keanu was about a guy that I
play named rel who has a cousin and
they're very related to Keegan in this
we are related but in real life only you
have kissed on yes okay how did you like
like brothers here with keegan-michael
key
one of the stars of this film Keanu yes
ti no it's uh it's gonna be a great
comedy romp it has cats and has breasts
it has gangsters breasts and gangsters
it's going to be a hard R this is
definitely gonna be a hard R it's
actually gonna be it's gonna be a rigid
R this movies for all people everywhere
impoverished or highfalutin
is it's for everyone there's movies for
everyone even Isis even Isis well ok no
I see your point
if you did not think screen junkies was
legit look who we got in our corner M
ETH OD man here he is the Method Man I
am a huge fan of the whoo of The Wire of
you but you recognized me you as soon as
I saw him I was like the guy from screen
junkies yes I am a subscriber I love
that room by the way you have almost
every toy that I've been want you can
come to that room I love that why don't
you play a nerd in a movie um cuz I play
a nerd in real life
all right I'm very excited I am here
with one of my favorite actors of all
time Boogie Nights Carlito's Way and
just a your IMDB page how long is your
IMDB page it's a summer read you have
any preference as far as playing bad
guys or nice guys it's nice to have a
job to go to good or bad okay but all
that both side come on you won't play a
tough guy or a nice guy okay number one
the more you touch me and you came into
my space right so I can be a bad guy
right now but I'm I'm a good guy I just
love to work okay the we understand each
other
yes okay keep it mom okay so I couldn't
tell if Louie Guzman was really mad or
just being the great actor that he is
anyway I wasn't taking any chances I
decided to keep a low profile and talk
to some of the crew behind the scenes
from the directors assistant you just
got a job with me I'm directing avatar 3
you can tell me deal-breaker or not I
need you to kill a man for me definitely
not a deal-breaker nice to a talented
stunt woman what would the first thing
I'd want to do if I want to become a
stunt man learn how to fall I fell once
it was directly it was right on to my
head yeah well that's not something well
I was a baby to a very nice camera
assistant what do you do on set my
camera assistant what does that mean
that means I assist the camera do you
need help on one shot calling cut or
action for the last time no all right
help thank you so much for offering it's
really great to your young player but no
all right I'll be ok if your voice gets
a little tired
that's it won't but thank you it was a
lot of fun talking to the cast and crew
but now I wanted my moment in the Sun
and not the New Orleans son that was
sapping my energy the spotlight so since
I was a veteran of Comedy Central's key
and Peele
I figured it should be no big deal for
me to get a part in the movie want to
give me a part today wanted just like
yes yes awesome oh my god let me know
how that works
well you know how that turns out you
know what there could be in this movie
like a really strong element of key and
Peele from two episodes how Rudnick what
about I think are you gonna actually
have to leave oh I have to go but I mean
I mean I'm here already
I was talking to Jordan before and he
said it was a good idea it's a Mexican
standoff what if the Jewish gang arrived
I think I think it's a great idea for
Keanu to or right now since we're all
here and have all the guns and stuff as
long as you brought your gun we're good
to go yeah I mean I couldn't borrow on
know they're all assigned to people
already unfortunately so now I'd managed
to piss off not only Louis Guzman but
the guy who wrangles guns on set I
thought all hope was lost until director
Peter Atencio gave me my moment to shine
ready on your marks get set
and action it ended well that was a lot
of fun so are you excited about this
movie are you a fan of key and Peele
have you seen my appearances on key and
Peele let us know in the comments
section below
we want to know don't forget to see
Keanu opening April 29th and thank you
to the entire cast and crew for having
us there and being wonderful hosts I
want to thank you for watching screen
junkies I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up on
Twitter bye-bye is Doctor Strange an
Avenger or has he been an Avenger how
does he fit into the big picture of the
MCU he's a tricky character to write for
because he is so powerful yeah it's like
oh uh you know like the Chitauri are
invading I know they're not